hey party people looking to us -
commentaries for Howard the Duck a
terrible film made for no one this is a
show where we talk about the honest
trail you hopefully just watch give some
of our background thought process behind
the jokes if you stick around to the end
some jokes that we cut from the final
cut if we have any we might we probably
do I spent skill work Dan merle-jo star
Daniel Radford hello hello this movie
sucked disgust yeah well you know that
was really the writing process behind
this particular project Spencer's that
this movie is a turd yeah it is is it as
a poopy turd look on Australia's gives
us the flexibility to be complimentary
of the films that are good and also to
take a steaming pile the ones that are
bad yes is the latter camp it was that
was glad you were back for this one I
didn't have a static rush so just like
remembrance of childhood no it's just
like this is not good now
this is bad I did but I someone must
have censored out all the duck nipples
like they had to me because I don't
remember the Ducks have nipples or in
the first file could you million but
they're mammals right now of course
right did I feed them you're thinking of
a boy as a platypus
yeah so sure I don't think they look
okay all right duck world Before we jump
into things let's really we're not done
on duck boobs there's there's four sets
of duck oh sorry
two pairs there's four more total boobs
yes
why if you're gonna do any why stop
there and right at the beginning of the
movie that's that's where my mindset is
is that it's like why didn't if you're
gonna just hit the ground running with
duck boobs why isn't this like a full
like duck showgirls well it relates to
my initial thing of this movies made for
nobody which is
that it's like you want to make a saucy
r-rated comedy where he's working it's
like the jizz mop or in a in a bathhouse
he's mopping up the bathhouse and people
are having sex there and or but but the
jokes are like PG they're like PG duck
pun jokes in a world of film yeah making
the end result just disorienting and
upsetting I think the worst thing he
says the worst things he's done there's
a million of them but the worst thing he
ever says is at one point he calls
someone a cracker and I was like I can't
believe he said that and I was like I
did he did work in that nasty nasty hot
tub I'm shocked that he didn't call him
a quacker and confusing just in context
of the film you know I bet that he did
say cracker and then someone was like no
we want him to be racist
George I want the doctor racist [ __ ]
there's decorations or anything this
movie made me want to replay the old
Leisure Suit Larry see yeah it had a
very Leisure Suit Larry vibe there's a
kinship yeah there's a kinship it just
like duck world just doesn't track for
me at all because everything there is
duck related but in a way that relies on
there being a human world to play off of
that's a ton yes like they had they must
know everything about our world to make
such spot-on pun versions of it because
breeders of the lost stork is only funny
as a play on Raiders of the Lost Ark
when if I'm assuming that the movie
version the duck version of Raiders of
the Lost Ark is the same I'm gonna
assume also that the plot is the same no
these breeders of Raiders of the Lost
Ark is a porn
the porn parody of their Raiders of the
Lost and l'art if all of this is
explained in Howard the Duck comics I'm
sorry I didn't read that absolutely
isn't I can't know that where did that
comics are like they're they're satire
all that duck world stuff gets added
later and the creator of Howard the Duck
hates all of that stuff he won't come
out ever publicly about not liking this
but he just likes much of what has been
done with Howard the Duck and there's
actually a really interesting maybe I'll
tweet it or something tonight there's a
really interesting story about how he
was doing a crossover between two books
and stole Howard the Duck back from
Marvel okay it's very interesting
interesting yeah so he's never come out
bad against this movie but you can't
possibly imagine that he really liked it
out okay at this point you're allowed to
yeah I mean it's like a it's like Ishtar
which isn't as bad as people say but
this is truly as awful as yeah let's
roll it let's watch Howard the Duck
again just the trailer right
[Music]
before marble wraps up a decade of
storytelling an endgame go back to where
their movies began
nope before that Thanks getting warmer
my little airbrushed beauty yep there it
is not some chucklehead in the comment
is going like there was actually a
Captain America before that it was a
short it was a not a feature-length
Captain America they were short they
played before other thirst TV yeah I
believe so
some like saved you a comment yeah we
had legitimate conversations about
whether we had to for D monetization
purposes censored those boobs oh the
duck nipples yeah yeah we had this is
the conversation we had to have this I
think it's funnier to censor them yes
because it lies that it is like a saucy
thing to show in the first place and
it's so ridiculous look at that someone
made that puppet like that or statue or
whatever it is yes someone sculpted that
yeah yeah that was their job that dad a
designer came in they had to decide how
big or small they were going to be yeah
the wig
someone had to make a special duck
corset some type of bustier of course
that they have like legs could be wrong
yeah all right get it off stop the dark
experience the first feature-length film
based on a Marvel comic that in a weird
way set the stage for things to come
featuring their first sky bean first
forgettable alien villain and first
alcoholic womanizing hero really the
only reason it failed is because they
got everything else wrong so very very
cute scary sexy he's supposed to be a
lovable hornball but
I don't know it just seems like like a
depressed screenwriters idea of what
like an appealing down-on-his-luck
duck I want to make millions of dollars
but I want to be subversive but I want
to be funny but I don't want it to be
funny but I want everyone to love it but
I hate myself yeah okay did he go to med
school or like he dropped out of duck
medical school which is a brand that
they don't pick duck legal score or
something - no he didn't say she wanted
to be a musician and he also wanted him
to be an ad copy writer so they wanted
him to be a plastic surgeon but he was
like nah and he decided to be a musician
then gave that up and became a
copywriter right yeah what you stole all
right guys it's still like a really good
job I don't know I get it but you can
play guitar on the weekend
[Laughter]
Howard dad yeah you can cover Def
Leppard on that weekend which in this
universe is called he really accepts his
situation from a sexual perspective very
quickly because he has the
understandable disgust towards Beverly
at the beginning the same way we would
be and you know not to not to kink shame
but if we came across an anthropomorphic
duck that we wouldn't want to have sex
with it
even if it were into us 110 percent he
warms to the ideas so fast
he's like takes like six hours maybe yes
is a time well I guess if I'm here yeah
I'm gonna go frolic with that well I
don't know man
she's also so tall I would never it
would have made more sense if she like
had you know something feathery on to
seduce him or like some type of duck
effort easy actually from throughbred
atom easy quack yeah I would never have
sex with an anthropomorphic duck Jo
protest too much
dan you wanna weigh in on this no okay
to rank a few yeah I mean Debbie's not
even wearing pants so he's ready to go
gizmo over launch pad gives but I don't
know just let's just go ahead and get
robot and duck out of the way in one
felony so even in this eye where we
would actually do a duck Howard is still
towards the bottom yes
yeah I think we can all agree on that
especially ban he would not be a
generous lover okay hard at the sued
because it's extremely gentle cop
shaking his arm when he split from duck
world and sent to Cleveland's glam rock
district he'll embark on an epic quest
to complain you know whatever zip it
now I'm really depressed while outside
forces
Leslie J the whole movie against his
will
he doesn't want to do anything
would you yes who want to go back to
duckling
it's okay Howard we don't want to be
here either but this duck won't fly
alone prepared I love someone
well I thought he never gets the hang of
that that glider scene is 40 minutes to
bunk out F his way through about 200
miles like like that's the first stage
of a wacky chasing but like every time I
come back he's like
[Music]
so the whole third act is like they they
take this is like the Blues Brothers
like supposedly big cop chase but the
thing just just never ends I I started
to fade out at this point and I just
remember every now and then looking back
at the screen and you can tell the movie
that's Tim Robbins I don't know if they
just overestimated people's interest in
ducks on biplanes or they're going man
or they just didn't have money because
they did so many reshoots that they were
forced to just like add more of this or
like one half of the movie takes place
in the Cajun sushi restaurant and the
other half of the movie takes place
during miss chase it's just not anywhere
near as clever as anyone thought it was
good to see you they really thought that
was gonna be super clever and then in
the end they ordered like chilli
Rihanna's O'Hara like huevos rancheros
or whatever it was but they really
thought that that was super clever and
it was just an excuse to be racist with
a with the question Tina like restore
water fights and diners like the canteen
American Graffiti doctor bayonet our
foreign foods this was the movie he
wanted to do before star worship so one
for me seelix wistfully out the window
over his over his winery pray for you
one for me one for me one more Ewok
movie charge and then it's done anyways
okay keep going
prepare for an ensemble film where every
character can be described as the dumb
one featuring Tim Robbins as the entire
cast of Big Bang Theory at once
the girl is down to experiment no matter
how wrong mewls my friend happiness in
the animal kingdom tacky because aside
from the fact that she's trading food
and shelter for sex - and I got the ASP
Ducks have corkscrew-shaped penises that
extend the links of their entire bodies
why is that condom unwrapped shouldn't
have an open one
it's a weird reveal of how little
everyone involved in this movie knew
about how sex works you don't need to
have a gigantic corkscrew-shaped one
because that's too much duck it should
be wrapped it really should be wrapped
Howard yeah it's in a party that's gross
and it made me think of things I didn't
want to think of yeah like if he's
reducing reusing and recycling it you
could have her a joke where the rapper
says webbed for her pleasure
you know these are easy these are more
easy jokes which the entire movie is
made of yeah and I used the word jokes
lose let's keep you know what duckville
is still better than bright ok spend the
links of their entire bodies this
relation shares all the laws of nature
but this isn't a serious bill meant to
be analyzed it's a goofy comedy and on
that level it's also terrible because
whatever problems you may have with the
MC use quips it's nothing compared to
the relentless barrage of duck puns
seeing-eye dog what's his the key to
your duck mobile apps and a master of
quack fool so many ducking puns then
these are fouled rap now they've got me
doing it
so settle in for what should have been a
superpower team-up between Marvel Comics
and George Lucas
yep that George Lucas that was such a
decision it snapped Marvel movies out of
existence for a decade this morning a
man exists that would go on to become
Pixar
so hey even if this duck sucked at least
it gave us a woody I'm sorry this this
is what happens when you watch Howard
the Duck more than once guys
thanks but once was plenty
starring snark winged duck madonna
Neal dumbass Tyson ferris bueller ducks
off now I like the music affair the duck
I will give it that it's Jordan there's
George Clinton and like Dolby right and
there's somebody making some actual pop
songs for this film that I don't think
are terrible yah-tchi except for his
solo he's playing a human guitar that
that's that's tough for him it should be
specialized but well the guitar is
personalized I think it says Howard on
the neck so clearly this was planned yes
he would be accidentally accidentally
placed but that happened at the end of
every eighties movie every movie from
1986 ends with the main character going
realizing they're on stage the last
dragon yeah Empire Strikes Back yeah
yeah basically a Thompson thought that
she was gonna just only be in movies and
guitar solos yeah a lot of careers ended
the writers went on vacation during that
weekend and stopped answering phone
calls that's true Wow really did they
know they must have known no it seems
like the first review came out they were
on a plane baby yeah but now it's like a
fun pop culture thing to be a part of
like
like now you can go back and be like and
yeah I feel like they keep just saying
but it doesn't matter how terrible
something is given enough time there
will always be a cult that pops up
around it that will want to talk to you
because they like that they like it
yes there's a certain appeal of garbage
JT moving hate to eat loves the movie as
a cabbie said you know was raised on it
on VHS from some weird uncle or
something like that and you know what if
you if it gets you early enough you know
you it's before you've developed your
crap radar you know even as a kid I was
like like I liked just as much garbage
as I do now as a child and I liked
Garbage Pail Kids and I think with this
movie I was like why is he still in that
glider yeah again the movie made for
nobody
before you do final thoughts let's see
if we have any deleted scenes anything
we cut so many ducting puns they don't
even make sense it's not like we drink
person wiser on earth and if the jokes
are for kids
why is everyone supporting this movie is
for know why this is beginning to
seriously undermine my self-esteem story
offensive foul horny yeah so these
graphics are so much better than this
movie deserves pulpy in a nut chance
usual better than we are this movie
deserves yeah 100%
yeah Marvel's come a long way you guys I
feel like this is before they really
took a interest or a care in what people
are doing with their IP on film and it
shows I felt like this was the
the obvious choice I mean it was really
our only choice for endgame well people
wanted us to do the event the 1998
Avengers you didn't really get these
injures I feel very friendly does from
an SEO perspective we could have gotten
lots of hits you know that would have
been the easy
clickbait thing to do right yeah no but
let's make fun of Marvel back when they
were sliding into bankruptcy
yeah a few more years left in the tank
like bankruptcy was the 90s right with
Wendy Marvin this was so much more fun
than the Avengers would have been yeah
maybe we left some views on the table
but we have to have fun too yes we're
gonna be like George Lucas one for me to
do the duck film yeah gosh what else can
you say about Howard the Duck
don't worry watch it no no we did it for
you we did it so you don't have to it's
one of those and I think everybody else
does that this has been Epic Meal Time I
hope you enjoyed movie turducken let's
start eating wings yeah
tune in next time for more hot ones okay
Joe Danielle me next week we will be and
will be will be catching something new I
think in the theater yeah yep so that'll
be fun and we'll see you then bye bye
[Music]